there's some news out of California
that's uh um getting some attention this
week um in fact an alleged hate crime
occurred in California if you can
believe it and here's a local news
reporting on this alleged hate crime
let's watch in other news at 10
disturbing video from San Pedro where a
man wakes up to find his newly painted
sports car vandalized with racist slurs
and a swastika and the victim says it is
not the first time people of color have
been targeted in his neighborhood ktla's
Rick Chambers live in San Pedro with a
story you'll see only on five
Rick yeah Micah while other vehicles in
this man's neighborhood have also been
vandalized in recent months this one
seemed more race-based and personal and
as you mentioned it apparently has
happened
before I can believe that this happened
to me in San Pedro Reginal Scott is
referring to the vandalism on his car
sometime between Christmas and New
Year's somebody spray painted his
Mustang using swas stickers and the
n-word they also slashed his tires he
says it might be a racial threat for
parking in front of someone else's home
even if you're parks where you're not
supposed to be I don't think that gives
you the right to spray paint on
somebody's car and call them a racial
slur that's that's that's hurtful it's
just wrong because they flatten his tire
they damage it and it's just something
that you don't want to see every day cuz
you know what if that could have been my
vehicle and Reginal Scott claims that
this has happened twice before somebody
set his truck on fire two years ago and
then um during Halloween they kept my
truck tires and sprayed some stuff all
over it to where I this is starting to
up and and we starting to get um scared
being around here so much so that he
keeps his son close by and says that his
wife now is scared
she don't want the doors to be unlocked
She Don't Want U she pretty much U has
on high alert the Scots say that they
filed a police report but now after 20
plus years in San Pedro it might be time
to
relocate if you think you'd like to help
the Scott family you can go to our
website at ktla.com we will have a link
to their go fundme page there in San
Pedro I'm Rick Chambers guys I'll throw
it back to you in the studio there it is
I was waiting for it the GoFundMe page
uh of course of course they have a
GoFundMe page what do you need funds for
because someone spray painted your car
like maybe I guess to get a paint job is
that all are they just are they just
going to raise a couple hundred bucks to
get a new paint job something tells me
probably not oh no they need to go they
need uh they need more money than that
just because it'll make them feel better
the only thing the only thing that can
that can heal the emotional trauma is
Cold Hard Cash that's the one thing that
could do it but you know the kid is
right um but what the kid said there I
think is right that he makes a good
point that just because someone parks in
your spot that doesn't give you the
right to spray paint racial slurs on his
car as tempting as it might be when
someone parks in your spot you know to
vandalize their car uh you don't have
the right to do that and and I would
agree with that and allegedly these uh
this this um Vandal spray painted you
couldn't really see it in the report
there but it was Merry Christmas nword
but they didn't say nword and then also
they spray painted a swastika on the car
and I don't know if you noticed but they
actually blurred out the swastika in the
because God forbid you can act you
actually see the swastika they won't let
you so they blurred that out but they it
was a swastika and um Merry Christmas N
word and I think we do we have the
pictures pull up just just just pull out
the swasa and that's the one we need to
see
um okay there it is keep that up on the
page there
because now first of all this is exactly
what you would
expect in the Nazi hotspot of San Pedro
California a place where where this man
and this man alone apparently has
repeatedly been targeted by
Nazis I don't know why they're picking
on him and nobody else I don't know what
it is but these are not it's very
interesting though because these are
Nazis who who oddly enough I mean
they're so dedicated to Nazism that
they're committing a hate crime that
would land them in federal prison for
years I mean if you really did something
like this and you were caught which you
would easily be caught by the way I mean
if you did this in the middle of some
was people have ring cameras and
security cameras and' be pretty easy to
find out who did it and you're going to
go to federal prison I mean they're
going to come down hard on you so these
are Nazis who are so but they're so
dedicated to their Nazi principles that
they said it's worth it I'll go to I'll
go to federal prison for 10 years just
to put the swats to go in the car but
then at the same time they're that
dedicated to Nazism but they're also so
clueless about Nazism that they don't
know how to draw a
swastika because that ain't it now I
know this is one of those things where
you really can't win like if you're
correcting someone SWAT stia uh I'm not
I'm not trying to claim that I'm the
swastika expert here but um that is not
actually what a swastika looks like and
uh well that's not a Nazi swasa anyway
that is that's actually closer to the
ancient Hindu
symbol that the Nazis took the swasa
from so maybe the
perpetrator is Hindu who
knows maybe this is a Hindu person fresh
off the boat
who's legitimately trying to be friendly
and but something's been Lost in
Translation I mean he did say Merry
Christmas balance of nature fruits and
veggies are a great way to make sure
you're getting essential nutritional
ingredients every single day balance of
nature uses an advanced cold vacuum
process that encapsulates fruits and
vegetables into Whole Food supplements
without sacrificing their natural
antioxidants the capsules are completely
void of additives uh fillers extracts
synthetics pesticides or added sugar the
only thing in balance of Nature's Food
and veggies capsules capsules are well
fruits and veggies right now not only
will my listeners get 35% off your first
order you'll now get a free fiber and
spice supplement as well balance of
Nature's fiber and spice supplement is a
revolutionary fiber drink with a unique
blend of 12 spices and Whole Foods our
office loves balance of Nature and uses
it every day there's never been an
easier way to make sure we're getting
our daily dose of fruits and vegetables
experience balance of nature for
yourself today go to balanceof
nature.com and use promo code Walsh for
35% off your first preferred order
uh plus get a free bottle of fiber and
spice that's balanceof nature.com promo
Cod Walsh for 35% off your first
preferred order plus a free bottle of
fiber and spice now you know of course
the media is reporting on this alleged
hate crime as
fact uh without a hint of
skepticism even though
like literally every case like this for
the last 20 years has been a hoax I mean
I mean every single one and you could
correct me if I'm wrong but has there
been a case of someone spray painting
the n-word or a swastika and it didn't
turn out to be done by the person who's
claiming to be the victim has there been
one case like that in 20
years I don't think
so um so every single case is a hoax but
the media reports this they don't even
say allegedly they just like yep it
happened this one this this one
all the other ones maybe not but this
one really happened and look I'm not
saying and I can't for legal reasons at
this point
say that this is definitely a
hoax um you know it's
not it's not
impossible that this guy was really
targeted by San Pedro Nazis it is
possible like it's logically technically
from a philosophical perspective
possible
you know people say when pigs fly right
when they're trying to indicate that
something didn't happen like when pigs
fly but but you know it's logically
possible for pigs to fly I mean there's
nothing impossible about it it's not
like a square circle or a married
Bachelor you know these are logical
contradictions and so they're therefore
philosophically impossible uh but but
there is a possible Universe where pigs
fly you know and and and and where a
sanpedro Nazi vandalizes a car there's
even even a possible Universe where a
flying Nazi Pig vandalizes a car that
that is also
possible and I'll go so far as to say
this to this guy's
credit if we do and you know the the uh
theoretical physicists and the
atheists they all speculate that we live
in a Multiverse with trillions of
realities playing out simultaneously in
different
dimensions and um and and if that's true
then I will even say that probably in
one of those realities this guy's story
is true you know of the trillions of
universes there's probably one where he
really his car really was vandalized by
a
Nazi it's just that that's almost
certainly not what happened in this
reality in this reality like we all know
that this is almost certainly a hoax
because again it always is a hoax and
it's so bad at this point and so
obvious that as soon as the story is
reported
every single comment now I mean you go
on Twitter go to the page with every
comment is like okay Jesse yeah all
right so these things happen and
everyone except the journalist reporting
on it know exactly what it is the moment
they hear about
it they know exactly what it almost
certainly is the moment they hear about
it um but we'll see you know this might
be look 20 years without a real uh
without a real hate crime like this
maybe this will be the first one and as
I said it' be very easy you know it's it
would not be hard to
find especially again in San Pedro like
there's there's probably only one white
guy on the entire block and I don't want
to cast dispersions on that one white
guy I'm just saying that like there's
probably only like one guy who could who
could even possibly
be which at least Narrows down the
search a little bit
if You' like to see what else I have to
say you can access my full show by going
to dailywire.com or by going to the Matt
wallow Twitter page hope to see you
there God speed